basic basic basic more basic that's
that's how you get there just keep doing
basic but uh when I come to teach I'm
trying to Now teach you where I'm
hopefully going so we want to go
somewhere um so my position is so s you
try and list how many techniques you
actually see them do on them films you
have a job to you know put 10 down
that's a lot of Coke in Aggie he doesn't
do many
techniques but in
the and as I
was I was saying earlier in the original
H Dojo he must have done because he
taught iido and in the arama he taught
techniques but when he went out of the
arama when the film Camas were rolling
he only done
COI because he said he didn't want
people to steal his uh techniques so he
gave it to his
students the rest of the world so we
watch all these films and I'm thinking
yeah but what he's doing we'd all like
to be like him so you know so I suddenly
realized a couple of years ago why do I
keep bothering with basic basic basic
and I want to really I started off want
to be like s why don't I try something
that's that stuff but I had to rethink
about it I was on a seminar I was trying
to think I think it was in Germany one
year but I was doing
this I wasn't doing this technique I
think it was in
rem no it wasn't doesn't matter but I
was doing this I realized that I
programmed myself to keep everything
within a measurement a bit like I was
saying with Dan he gets to here and then
he decides there and then all of a
sudden for some reason whether I've been
training or lot and I was tired but I
don't know all of a sudden I S I had an
extra piece of technique
I didn't have extra technique I had
extra movement instead of going always
there I S I thought wow I can go there
it's a bit stupid like a child going wow
never seen that before it's me you know
so I realize you can actually like you
know I get there my necks get locked
yeah that's about it then sudden you see
he's going if you can't go down here you
can't do
like how's he got down there so you
start chall yourself and then you find
you can go down there after a bit of
work and all a sudden you got lots more
knowledge about techniques
so so so what I'm trying to do tonight
is really is a celebration I'm trying to
show you
that you need to sort of
think how far can I go before it starts
getting ragged how far can I go before I
it starts becoming it's not got quality
to it anymore it's got to have quality
to everything you do whereas you lose it
being a martial art it becomes a dance
just becomes something
flare so it's always got to work in in
my eyes it has must work in a mar in a
marshal
way give it but you don't let take it so
take trying
[Music]
to so what I'm
doing
this this this way for I
again it's
skill I get exactly the right place for
the Nikos I don't get just
somewhere get
here there's so many techniques in there
you only do short pieces of
them when when you need
them short
pieces not get too
complicated this one you can
do
guys this one you can do you got to get
it so your little finger doesn't impinge
on that joint if it
does no way will I get if it slips out
Jo you've got a lovely
technique so so you make mistake oh c
get I can see watching he wants this
one I used to the
same watch my for
minute's that
so when I S he said there's thousands of
techniques in
Tapp what he means is you can overlap
them and repeat them so when I go like
this I'm really do the same footwork as
the
car you know the that one on this hand
it would be on this hand but now when I
do
that get the footwork of
but my whole belief is please go past
please go past I'm having
to I'm having to get out of the way of
everything I offer
him so that he can be
trapped if this foot
lo I think I'm digging hold this out
explain it um let's try if you go one
way you do c guys you go the other way
it looks like
EO so it looks like Iko but I get to
about I get to about there and I
go and I just do a little nck on
him because I've only got one hand on
him and I might he might be strong
but if I
float I think the Niko I can put the
power just on the WR at the same time